peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut que les gens quittent et yuki où
il était le gentil qui sont ils et elles
ou 1
ils étaient où où il était le gentil ce
qui nous était pas clair s'il était ou
non pas par le compétence coûteront kiki
frère et sa mère alors sa mère l'a même
fait mouche elle était où
1 sa mère qui veut d'autre issue qu'avec
à mouches il est sinon le youki il était
gentil toutou
nous qui critiquent et où il était
[Musique]
on sait qu'il était sur la piste et son
père ont fait qu'un petit coup c'est
qu'il était papa
[Musique]
il était là le bouzouki choo il était là
le plus beau du cou qui s'il était là
qui le faut peu pour le plus joli de
tous les votes ont été acquis 12 a
certes été agressée télé papadopoli et
la course et diac ses alliés qu'ils
adopteront et le youki alors il est
acquis a dit c'est qu'il a maintenant
pignon à guissény
le breton a sent pas bon au gaz animaux
[Musique]
yuki
qu'est ce qu'ils appellent à houla la
ville en turquie un an j'ai beaucoup de
sacs a plombé les photos il un tocard
longues études techniques et c'est la
grande écoute on est pas couché là vous
de vous coucher où le méchant fois que
vous poussiez pour fédérer passé tu t'es
beau père est en colère le père ayew
compellent et beaucoup d'ong avaient si
bien en feront le plus que tu cette
équipe mais qui s'est dit l'un d'eux
plus tôt cette équipe sait qui c'est
clair que tu es seul essai s'était pas
ton papier le pq peut alors ce qu'il
veut avec son papy conserver
de toute façon c'est pas le loup qui
s'était pas tout à fait
de toute façon c'était pas le tfc n'a
pas senti le plus que tu as écrit le
club avec qui ses sont pas punis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]